[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous sommes
de retour au Parlement européen à
Strasbourg ou vient de s'achever la
session plénière de janvier une session
encore fortement secouée par les suites
du Qatar game cette affaire de
corruption présumée d'actuelle et
d'anciens députés européens qui a fait
l'effet d'une bombe ici il y a un mois
aujourd'hui le Parlement tente de faire
face au plus grand scandale de son
histoire comment l'institution va-t-elle
redresser la barre c'est ce que nous
allons voir avec nos invités Véronique
Leblanc bonjour vous êtes correspondant
de La Libre Belgique et de l'agence
Europe Daniel froide bonjour vous êtes
heureux député Vert allemand
Marie-Pierre vedrel bonjour vous êtes
heureux député donc française du groupe
prognoux et vous co présidez la
délégation française et enfin Benoît
Lutgen vous êtes heureux député belge du
groupe du PPE du Parti populaire
européen avec vous nous allons revenir
sur ce scandale qui continue à faire
trembler le Parlement européen
Marie-Pierre au-delà de la
stupéfaction et de la colère que vous
avez certainement du ressentir quel a
été votre réaction car ces allégations
de corruption de quelques individu ont
jeté l'eau propre sur l'ensemble de
l'institution bien sûr vous avez raison
de souligner que c'est un risque
indéniable et on le voit bien quand on
échange avec nos concitoyens le côté
tous pourri revient et j'ai été
effectivement aussi l'eau propre comme
le disait mon collègue sur tout le
travail qu'on peut mener justement aussi
d'une voix forte du Parlement européen
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur donc il y a le
il y a les deux volets à la fois le tout
pourri et à la fois la perte d'influence
ou de légitimité de notre travail donc
ça c'est pour ça qu'on a tous dit aussi
parce qu'il faut bien dire que justement
ce ne sont que quelques exceptions et on
continuera justement de contribuer à
faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait plus ses
exceptions et vraiment à à dire que le
Parlement européen se tient à
disposition de la justice et on montre
ça nous montre aussi que ça a été dit
par mon président de groupe l'État de
droit est important et fonctionne et a
pu justement mettre en avant cette
corruption donc il nous faut continuer
de dire que le Parlement européen
n'accepte pas la corruption en son sein
pas piqué Marie-Pierre vedren ses
propositions vous paraissent-elles
quelles proposition vous paraissent les
plus pertinentes ou incontournables en
tout cas en matière de transparence et
de lutte anti corruption en fait je
pense qu'il y a aussi comme au travers
de votre question et les différents
points qui étaient intervenez avec
l'intervention de Robert intermezzola on
voit qu'il y a différentes choses il y a
la question effectivement de la
transparence la question du conflit
d'intérêt la question de l'ingérence ces
propositions elles visent aussi à
répondre justement à chacun de ces
enjeux mais si on travaille pas déjà sur
la transparence effectivement on
n'avance pas sur chacun des autres
sujets nous c'est vrai que et en plus on
a ce système en France de Haute Autorité
en exemple dans cette histoire la vie
publique alors on voit alors vous pouvez
peut-être nous expliquer vous pouvez
peut-être nous expliquer comment ça
fonctionne puisque l'été spectateurs ne
le savent pas forcément d'ailleurs en
tant qu'Euro député française vous êtes
tenu de déclarer expliquez-nous comment
ça marche donc effectivement il y a ce
qui évoquait notre collègue les
déclarations au niveau du Parlement
européen et où il y a contrôle et puis
il y a la déclaration en France sur le
patrimoine que j'ai en début de mandat
en début de mandat aussi tout Le pendant
les 10 dernières années avant que j'ai
exercé comme métier donc si je suis dans
des conseils d'administration à titre
bénévoles à titre rémunéré tout ça et
donner je transmets les informations si
je ne les transmets pas je suis relancé
je suis invité plus qu'invité aller et
la même chose est fait en fin de mandat
exactement pour quelle raison pour voir
s'il n'y a pas eu d'enrichissement
justement du fait du mandat donc ça
c'est un élément extrêmement important
c'est pour ça que c'est vrai que c'est
pas nécessairement la culture politique
dans tous les États membres mais pour
nous ça nous semble important d'avancer
sur cette enjeu parce qu'en plus
j'entends certains collègues qui dit oui
mais sur le patrimoine que ça soit sur
la place publique en quelque sorte
certains seraient plutôt gênés sur cette
question là aussi c'est des choses qui
sont à la préfecture qui sont
consultables par tout le monde mais qui
ne sont pas nécessairement étal sur la
place publique donc on explique aussi on
fait ce travail de pédagogie auprès de
tous nos collègues pour aller dans ce
sens est-ce qu'on s'attaque avec tout ça
vraiment au vrai problème il y a
peut-être des règles très simples et ce
qu'il ne faudrait pas interdire une
activité rémunérée au zéro député
parallèlement à leur mandat pour éviter
tout conflit d'intérêt qui souhaitent
réagir Marie-Pierre peut-être parce que
je pense oui il y a énormément de choses
à faire aussi sur cette question après
pour rebondir sur les échanges qu'on
avait je pense qu'il faut aussi faire
attention moi par exemple avant d'être
député européenne je suis j'étais lu en
2019 j'ai travaillé dans le privé dans
l'éolien est-ce que parce que j'ai
travaillé dans l'éolien je vous voyez
est-ce que vous pouvez vous retrouver en
situation de conflit d'intérêt est-ce
que vous avez travaillé sur un rapport
sur les éoliennes par exemple non parce
que je suis dans la Commission
internationale mais en même temps à un
moment on vote tous l'ensemble des
sujets et parce que je vais soutenir le
développement de l'éolien
après il y a une question et la pression
des sociétés civiles françaises
notamment et je vois bien ah mais c'est
parce qu'elle aurait travaillé dans le
lien qu'elle va voter ça non c'est parce
que je crois que c'est extrêmement
important que pour répondre aux enjeux
du changement climatique il faut
développer les énergies renouvelables
donc je pense qu'il faut faire attention
aussi à pas tout mélanger sur les
questions de conflit d'intérêt justement
à la fois dans le parcours qui ont eu
des parlementaires qui pour le coup
n'ont pas justement eu une activité
politique tout au long de leur carrière
mais c'est vrai que par rapport au point
que vous évoquez sur au moment du mandat
là ça pose quand même extrêmement
question parce qu'il y a aussi cette
question effectivement de à la fin du
mandat certains députés européens
quelquefois deviennent lobbyiste est-ce
que là il ne faut pas aussi pendant un
certain temps interdire cette
reconversion j'allais dire Marie-Pierre
vedren
oui moi je pense qu'il faut travailler
sur cet enjeu là aussi parce que là
c'est quand même très très gênant et
effectivement c'est valable aussi et je
partage jusqu'à dit mon collègue parce
que forcément là on est focalisé aussi
sur les députés mais c'est valable aussi
pas que pour les députés il faut
travailler aussi on l'a bien vu tout à
l'heure quand vous rappeliez l'effet il
y a pas que les anciens députés il y a
un problème
encadrer la présence des anciens députés
dans les locaux du Parlement et ça je
pense que c'est un élément important
surtout quand c'est des collègues
parfois de votre propre groupe politique
de votre propre nationalité donc on le
sait bien c'est des éléments extrêmement
importants pour autant je pense qu'il
faut faire attention à pas tomber dans
les travers de ça je m'explique je vous
le disais moi j'étais avant dans le
secteur privé je ne sais pas ce qui se
passera dans quelques années bien sûr je
suis encore jeune tous les débats qu'on
a en France sur la retraite vous allez
reprendre une autre activité
donc il faut être aussi il faut encadrer
il faut structurer les choses mais pas
tomber dans l'extrême une toute petite
minute j'aimerais que chacun très
brièvement en une phrase me dise quelle
est la mesure la plus importante à
mettre en oeuvre pour réformer les
institution très rapidement la Haute
autorité pour nous c'est extrême quelque
chose d'extrêmement important mais
l'indépendance est et les sanctions qui
vont derrière la mise en œuvre monsieur